let's serve up some news sunny side up
okay first up
get ready for your heart to swell and
maybe even burst on this one
a husband and wife from ecuador have
just earned the guinness world record
for the world's
oldest married couple i know
no it gets better julio mora is a
hundred
and ten and his wife waldromina
quinteros is 104 that's a combined age
of
214 years but
they tied the knot in 1941 and now they
have
11 grandchildren 21 great-grandchildren
and nine great-great-grandchildren
to show for it julio and waldromina say
their secret formula to 79
years of marriage is simple love
maturity
and mutual respect
i mean i just drink that up that is just
that is so life-affirming thank you so
much for that story
okay next up i don't know about you but
i love pets wearing people's clothes
and like this delightful i do this wait
till you see this
this dog named blinky eastman check out
this dapper little pup there he is
during a workout oh
rocking the van go oh
channeling his sean white oh hello
and working out again he's athletic oh
carmen miranda
there we go yeah well i'll see you at
fashion week blinky
all right and you too vanessa um listen
it's time for um food news
this information blew my mind now we all
know about the pumpkin spice latte
i mean it's like every year now it's the
biggest thing but how did it come to be
well fun fact bustle has a history of
the psl the pumpkin spice latte
and here are two things that i learned
first
starbucks employees literally just sat
around and ate pumpkin pie
while drinking espresso and then thought
how can we combine these flavors
and that's how the psl was born wow
that's a fun day at work i also learned
that it was almost called the full
harvest latte
and the reason they didn't go with it is
because it didn't describe the flavor
listen pumpkin spice has become so
synonymous with fall that none of us can
imagine life without it and thanks to
those two dudes
who uh you know were at work hanging out
came up with the whole thing i hope they
got a cut of it all right
good for you guys thank you change the
world okay
another way to get into the spirit of
the season is fall fashion trends and
this year pop sugar says look no further
than the card again
don't mind if i do let's all channel our
inner mr rogers
plus taylor swift loves them so much
that she sings about them on her latest
album and sent
actual little cardigans to all her
friends including jonathan van ness
who's on the show
[Music]
today